je vis de versements serviront pas si
brésilien
bonjour ma très chère amie et vous-même
paraissait forte à l'aig mais dix points
l'air célèbre de la tosca que vous
chantiez annonce est un art célèbres
d'opéras mais celui marguerite de fonds
à l'opéra faust marguerite au monde
marguerite quelle heure est il
exactement je viens d'entendre eux le
dernier bateau arrivé là haut le bateau
est une catastrophe
marguerite ans mais de qui parlez-vous
caissettes marguet et bien voilà c'est
un secret mais je suis heureux conseil
est la première à l'apprendre secret dit
m'a vite vous mettez l'eau à la bouche
et bien après de longues et difficiles
démarche j'ai pu intervenir dans les
deux enfants la grande cantatrice
marguerite papon
boyau pondu par tout net le dites pas
que vous connaissez pas eh bien monsieur
19 j'aime beaucoup l'opéra mais je n'ai
pas souvent l'occasion d'y aller et bien
grâce à moi vous allez découvrir son
immense talent bon je vous quitte je
vais la recevoir quant à leur tutelle f
ah j'oubliais et surtout pas un mot de
tout ceci à quiconque
c'est une surprise attend 10 mois je
vais mettre 20 plus belles anglaises la
vase est épouvantable je ne sors pas je
n'arrive pas à faire ce noeud de cravate
il faut pourtant que ce soit très beau
pour la recevoir françois utile a pour
toi françois fait moi je dis est il des
émeutiers ou casimir quelle élégance que
se passe-t-il c'est un secret secret je
vais te le dire mais tu seras le sol pas
le connaître ma tante adélaïde a décidé
de venir nous rendre visite dans l'île
et la vie par le bateau de ce soir est à
la porte des colis plein de chocolat et
de confiture par le bateau de ce soir
mais mon pauvre casimir dû être en
retard je viens d'entendre la sirène
justement elle a déjà gravi les devine
vite j'arrête oui mais quoi
quand tu es sur jim des flèches mais on
pense à ça tout à l'heure
[Musique]
bonjour madame
julie dit donc c'est l'europe
merveilleux n'est pas les inviter à une
soirée je suis désolé françois j'ai
promis de ne rien dire c'est un sacré
[Musique]
aussi que les secours on a donc à ce que
toi tu sais où si oui oui
je devais être en retard il n'y avait
personne sur le port j'espère qu'on ne
s'est pas perdue dans l'île aux enfants
avec tous ses bagages ses dix neuf ne
vous inquiétez pas trop vous savez une
autre il est tout petit et puis casimir
est parti la chercher casimir 8e pas
lourd sans culture mais c'est encore
plus catastrophique que j'ai pensé moi
lyon françois c'est tout pouvant table
c'est une catastrophe comme les émirs ne
me dis pas que toi aussi d'une la rater
mais si si j'étais en retard et lorsque
je suis arrivée sur le port il n'y avait
plus personne
à mettre ma jolie robe une femme si
merveilleuse avec tant de talent en a
qui dit vous massez doucement tout ce
qu'elle fait et délicieux
c'est délicieux c'est bien le mot pour
chacun c'est un vrai régal non mais je
ne savais pas que vous étiez assis
grands gourmands mais dis-moi casimir je
ne savais pas que tu aies sais que tu
étais si fins connaisseurs j'y pense qui
vous a prévenu de sa visite temps a
prévenu mais c'est grâce à moi si elle
commet grâce à vous
je suis heureuse de vous trouver ici oui
je viens de rencontrer les acteurs qui
m'a demandé de vous remettre de
télégrammes l'habitat pour messier
disney et un fossé gros canard yvonne
dahl et c'est sûrement sociale ou non
possible venir à bientôt peut-être en ni
de dernière minute moyen âge repoussé
signé la grande cantatrice marguerite
papon signé ta tante adélaïde cantatrice
battant d'adélaïde mais alors nous ne
parlons pas de la même porte à julie
mythe mais tu as parfaitement raison il
s'agit d'acquis pour coup franc qui
prend points un quiproquo
alors je me disais aussi que casimir us
ne pouvait apprécier un art aussi
délicat que l'opéra
laissez moi rire vous croyez être le
seul à être un grand artiste
d'ailleurs je frémis à l'idée que
marguerite papou la grande cantatrice a
failli voyager avec ta tante adélaïde
moment mais ma tante est une grande
artiste en cuisine c'est bien ce que je
voulais dire en commentaire votre compte
attriste n'est même pas digne de lui
serrer la main qua non oui absolument
qu'est-ce que tu étais une crieuse
d'opération des membres ayant arrêté
immédiatement au même véhicule
alors parce que d'après j une chanteuse
d'opéra une cuisinière ne peut pas
entend bien évidemment nombre d'arbres
c'est l'évidence même
alors écoutez plutôt la lettre expresse
que m'a donnée le facteur en même temps
qu'ils vont juger les graves
ma chère et demi
moi
puisque nous avons raté le bateau pour
l'île aux enfants nous avons décidé de
passer une soirée entre nous en
préparant toutes les deux havre ont
aussi il est tuant chantent en choeur dr
doté si cela te dis viens nous rejoindre
on s'amusera bien toutes les trois
signes étaient amis marguerite est admis
mais c'est formidable